you
gaspar speckle 1964 Columbia Business
School the possibility at that time to
come to the u.s. and to come to a
business school like Columbia was
sensational the second most important
part was the possibility to stay at
International House is a great mixture
fifty percent Americans fifty percent
internationals and that founded lifelong
friendships from different countries and
we see each other every two or three
years and that's a very special Columbia
group were so many interesting students
that Easter we went down south and we
had an American girl along we lifted
international house but at the filling
station she was told she couldn't go to
the toilet with our Gillian friend and
45 years later you have Obama so you
experience a real great change your soul
at that time was a spectacular
spectacular building and it also at that
time already much oriented towards group
work in a group work structure and other
forms of Education which we didn't have
before but what I and we really learned
was a case material and all this was it
the kind of learning which we did not
have at that time in Austria
when I came back 1972 we formed the
columbia business school club to get to
build a couple of law students for
germany austria and switzerland and we
had our 40th meeting last year this was
a certainly a big big surprise they give
presented me to the 700 mba is needed
look he is already 40 years and you have
to sign up right now so you make make it
up to 40 years to
you